[Music]
I'm so glad you got my memo oh yeah
Sparkles sparkly Blazer Blazers let's be
sparkly together
is it working on the black carpet I
think it is yeah there's a lot going on
let's get some of the flood that's
happening though if you could help us
out with that yeah you're the one that
knows how to apocalypse I could start to
uh do a little Gene Kelly Singing in the
Rain yeah it was yeah I would love that
that's not how you doing Daddy I'm all
right Mama
we're finally here how do you describe
this moment it's amazing we shot this
for a year you know I got to Calgary uh
June uh 2021 and left June 2022 and uh
and now here we are in 2023 and uh it's
finally here and we've all been together
for so long working so hard and we're
all dying to see it and
and and yet weirdly I wish I could kind
of paralyze the experience and it never
really actually happened it will be had
such a good time doing it we all got so
we became so close and um and so it's
kind of you know
I I want to just sort of put that in a
time capsule and and make that never
change yeah who's the better
um carpool friend garogu or Ellie
oh shoot
um
yeah exactly Ellie can talk back yeah
but but grogu could like lift me with
the force and toss me across the room
yeah if you wanted to although he never
would we know that
[Music]
I gotta wrap up but I know you know
you're the daddy of the internet right I
called Pedro pascala dilf and think he's
my cool [ __ ] father
yep I am your cool [ __ ] daddy you are
Delight so good to see you good to see
you too
[Music]